[Musica]
beh ragazzi queste di chi è venuto come
sai da tutti tra l'altro buonasera
magari io sto guardando alle 7 del
mattino e cristo però va bene è venuto
nichi a casa a trovarmi e siccome c'è un
gioco che io non faccio mai perché succo
a bestia oggi ci giochi insieme a nicky
che invece il massimo esperto di fifa e
quindi oggi giochiamo a fifa ragazzi per
tutti quelli che sono appassionati di
calcio
io sì e tocca un pallone esplode se ti
veniva era ti giuro da un monumento dai
chelsea io prendo il borussia ma donna
bellissima bellissima
no no se entrava bellissimi seguito
uccidere tutti quello che potevo ma cosa
fare mi dieta non ho capito ma
analizziamo la partita che sta cosa sta
diventando già troppo imbarazzata
comunque rigori già non c'arriva rigori
perché vi giuro cioè spengono la place
tela risolviamo la vecchia maniera se
dobbiamo rivedere i tories piacere tra
che sono abbiamo intravisto nostro
accesso al campo è passato la poesia si
fa attenzione a son capaci aiuto non
sapevi giocare bastardo attenzione no no
vabbè però gigi l'altro qua se fai una
cittadino vede lo vede lo vede non
rivede no
berlino cos'è che difesa che ho
attenzione madonna
no no non ci posso crema concentrando
bravo bravissimo madonna come tu porca
vacca non entra mai staff all'addio
madonna centrale vento pinball perché mi
fa strano io riesca a fare delle azioni
guadagna metri personali oa un bavaglio
anzi gira può tentare la botta umani
younger non mi sa che cosa o familiare
10 palla al centro ma mi yang pinna
antica saremo che poi inizio l'x vai
cosa stavo dicendo ma attenzione dopo mi
yang è pronto e vuole correre e lui
davanti al portiere pallonetto
questo ci ho provato per fortuna e altri
tifosi talenti e diane all ultimazione
me la fanno fare forse lamina d se fosse
entrata ragazza è stata una bella
partita
2 a 0 certo questo termine squadra che
sono fortissimi e casuale 311 francia
contro landa cup olanda martin garics
calciato arte comunque se una di queste
ragazze il viaggio della calcio come di
tipo mimì lancia importa sicuramente
madonna mia la botta cosa quanto ci sono
picchia rigore è rigorosa rigore ma non
ho fatto niente ma lasciati da gestire
posso giocare a pippa un gioco che mi va
contro in qualsiasi cosa e come calci e
pugni sono volati attenzione a cosa fa
reazione incredibile quella del portiere
amici che cazzo riti che cazzo riti h
che gioca un brutto dagli chiama tecnico
mi sento sempre rigorissimo quando parli
video fare prego perché sennò è rigore
che cosa sto facendo il mio portiere le
somme a quanto già visto battere i
rigori comunque che la norma
impostazioni separare il momento
interdizione passaglia non ha più la
forza neanche per reggersi in piedi però
di impostare l'azione è sempre di marca
sono morti tutti è diventato battlefield
a una cerci orasi tutti in super
incazzati tra l'altro ma meno male ma la
moneta finalmente un ammonito d'olio 20
jolly punizione tattica
ok allora rosi pronto e modo importa con
due persone veniva descritto holland
dietro se tra metto dove c'è la la prima
l
adesso questo giocatore bastardo ha
visto quello che si era spostata non so
se cercate comete la vede anzi in un
limbo era una delle scorregge che volete
il mondo ma attenzione va a festeggiare
sotto porta così a puoi andare in giro a
festeggiare sì ma prendendo un caffè mi
prudono le teste rasate problema quando
mandai fammi questo maledetto gol ma non
puoi tirare da dove non stavo tirando
non è un tiro era un passaggio da quel
problema
lanciato una mina no ma che cacciare un
missile caduto il cuore al e festeggiano
anche madonna
io non ci gioco ma è fifa mi fa
veramente schifo è un gioco un minuto
raga cancellare tre youtubers annuncerò
venite da me presentato la giochi veri
per veri videogiocatori non fifa che ci
giocano anche mia nonna
anzi è tipo è mai provato sì ma per una
rai 20 all'ultima fila arabia saudita
dai al hilal
io prendo al shabab si chiama un kebab
in macchina subito dopo che si stia
giocando al khali gente è l'unica che ha
una stella sola io la prendo perché ci
credo al bateen al patibolo allora la
rabbia non mi deluderà ultima partita di
oggi ragazzi ma la partita in cui io mi
riscatti vince questa squadra del jazz
perché non ce la fai cagare un problema
ultima vinci pesanti sta giocando
madonna ragazza stava entrando in mezzo
fa salire la squadra
news non farle ramacca e aldo giovanni
villano si ok ok ok scarica city ok è
bravo nel passaggio ma perché così lento
quando la palla diventa un dittico di
hacker che fa è molto più fisico adesso
questo nessuna pieta e cattivissimo
recupera palla la posta
andiamo a festeggiare così vive moro è
morto e spacciato il ginocchio ma dopo
un criminale
non ci credo una serie di in palestra
fortunati double up anzi tua madre è un
portiere più su abbia del mondo è ora la
posa e guarda i pantaloni come
chiaramente mai rubati da e malate
olindo incredibili pantaloni più brutti
della storia pancaldo bestia poi certo
inventa con i bordi senato è uscito
madonna mia che grande assist e cita il
suo fischiata e anche così a
concentrando madonna dai ricordi iori
con almeno un rigore almeno non segnerò
ma povero soggetto prima lei gli ha
sparato in attenzione purissimo però
siamo ritornati borgaro area mother
father altro cosa che stavano uscendo di
brutto
beck è necessario rigore ma insomma li
sordi le 100.000 e abdullah al salemme
150 scavalca e per alzare chiama
abdullah saleh
a salemme perché al prosciutto so che
migliori menti mai mastrolindo no
arrivato cazzutissima vediamo però
ripeto che secondo me l'uomo più bello
del ancora lui davanti alla porta da
solo con la sua e possono ripartire
ho fatto un casino ma fate attenzione ma
dopo il muratore e sino cosa so cosa
cosa non preso sul serio
secondo me li ho creato il joystick noti
giuridico 19 fuorigioco york arbitro
porca vacca tempestive
ma cosa ma dai ma stavo andando in
formato a quanto li hanno pagati stia
arbitri aveva stava basta non mi piace
questi giorni ho giocato a roma troppo
forte giocatasi al car hackett mario che
non siete capaci
va bene basta raga io direi che possiamo
concludere qui tira su di morale si è
ricordati basta basta giochiamo a cose
serie non questi giochi per bambini
è vero little di per l'eni il gioco a
premi joyce e i ragazzi noi adesso
giochiamo a giochi per uomini non quella
roba di prima ecco vedi d'oro sono
numerosi impegni ora sanno che significa
divertenti e scavati tocchi possono
guardare ovunque scorge la famiglia
prende joystick epifani poi in culo che
sentiste catania non lo caricherà questo
video mi rifiuto di ragazzi serviva
almeno per pietà cioè saresti state ci
vediamo al prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]